- Welcome into another
edition of Market Takes.
Look, I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you were here with
me and I appreciate that.
I am Dion Rabouin, Reporter
at the Wall Street Journal
and you know there is a lot
going on this week in the world
of markets and economics,
but I'm gonna tell you
the three most important things
you need to be watching out for this week
and it is a big one.
Look, this week we got the CPI
report, consumer price index,
the inflation report that's
really most dedicated
to what's going on with
consumers, you and me,
what we're doing, what we're spending
and how we're spending.
That report is gonna show us
where inflation is landed.
We get that tomorrow.
We will be right here for Market Takes.
I hope you'll be with us.
Wednesday, the Federal Reserve meets
the FOMC policy rate decision.
That's going on on Wednesday.
We'll be right here again
on Market Takes at 4:00 PM,
Hope you'll join us then as well.
And then Thursday we've got Retail sales.
So we're gonna break
down what all those are,
what you should be watching
for each one of those reports.
Let's start with CPI.
Wanna put a chart up here
on your screen to just
kick things off with that.
Now we have seen inflation
cooling since the middle of 2022.
Now you see there on your
screen the chart rising.
You see those bars getting higher.
We reached 9% in June and ever since then
really inflation has been
coming down on the CPI.
But you've seen there towards the end
the bar's not really
moving significantly lower.
You see a defined lower
numbers on each of those bars.
And then the last couple months
have been right around 5%.
5% definitely lower than 9%
but very far from the Feds 2%
target, which it, you know,
we're seeing a more than double.
So again, worrying that
inflation could be stuck
at this 5% level is
what's got some economists
a little worry about that.
And that chart just
illustrating, like we said
that inflation had been
coming down consistently
but it stalled out there.
And if it continues to stall
out, that could be trouble.
That could mean the Feds gotta do more
raise interest rates even more,
do more to choke off and sort
of slow down the economy.
Economists however, are expecting that CPI
is gonna come down to 4% for this month,
or at least for last month in the report
that we get this month.
4% which would be very
bullish for the market
and definitely bullish for stocks.
Recent data, however, has
suggested that that inflation
cooling trend that we have seen
for most of this year could be slowing.
We've seen home sales starting to pick up,
particularly new home
sales reached the highest
since March, 2022 last month.
We've also seen housing permits pick up
and home builder
confidence actually reached
a 10 month high last month.
We have also seen inventory
of expected homes 44% lower
than it was pre pandemic, or 44% lower
than their pre pandemic levels.
We are also seeing
business activity rising
to a 13 month high according to the S&P
purchasing managers index
and Retail sales rising surprisingly
last month when we expected a decline.
We will talk more about
that in just a moment.
So all these things have
suggested the consumer
continues to go out and spend.
Folks are still spending money
even though prices are still rising
at a pretty fast clip,
remember 5% inflation is still much faster
than anything we have seen
in the past 20 years or so.
So prices still continuing to rise.
And also those net profit
margins, we saw for Q1
now that we've seen about
99% of S&P 500 companies
report their earnings.
We have seen profit margins rise again
for most of those companies in Q1.
If you wanna continue to
see growth for companies
they usually have to continue
to keep raising those prices in Q2.
So we will see if that is continued.
Definitely CPI will be a
report to keep your eye on.
Also, you'll wanna watch Core CPI.
That number has been higher
while we have seen CPI
continue to come down,
Core CPI has held higher.
Usually you need Core CPI to come down
or the Fed starts to get worried.
Definitely something
you'll wanna watch out for.
Which brings us to, of course
the next big thing to watch this week.
That is the FOMC policy meeting,
Federal Open Markets Committee.
That's where they decide what
they're gonna do about rates.
Now this month it's not
about the actual decision,
it's not about is the Fed
gonna raise rates or not.
The market is convinced
the Fed is going to stop.
The question is, is
that a pause or a skip?
Are they stopping because
they're gonna hold rates here
at this level
or are they just pausing really quickly
and then going to start raising
them again starting in July?
The market is not quite
certain about that.
We're locked in for a pause this week.
But when we get the summary
of economic projections
the dot plot, when we see the statement
and we hear from Fed chair Jerome Powell
that's what's gonna move the market.
So you're gonna watch out for those.
And again, we will be with
you after that to break down
everything that was said and
everything that happened.
We've seen some disagreement
coming into this meeting.
Some Fed officials say, look,
inflation's starting to pick back up.
They point to those home sales number,
they point to the jobs growth,
they point to some of these
other data business sentiment
and all that, and they say, listen,
inflation's gonna pick back up.
We've gotta be proactive.
Even if we stop here
we've gotta start raising again in July.
While some other Fed officials say,
no, we may have already done too much.
We've gotta pause,
we've gotta make clear to the market
that we're not gonna do too
much and really send the country
into a needless and unnecessary
avoidable recession.
So that's what you've got coming in.
CPI will be a big
determinant of what that is
and how Fed officials respond.
And then we're gonna hear
from them on Wednesday.
So we are going to get a
chance to see what they say
and hear what they think.
And then of course we'll
hear from the chairman
at 2:30 on Wednesday.
Markets no longer pricing in
multiple rate cuts this year.
In fact, markets are pricing
in a rate hike in July.
And then after that, we'll see
and we're gonna get a lot of clarity
on what that is going
to be from the market.
Wanna show you one more quick thing
and put a chart up here on your screen.
And this right here,
what you're seeing is
the former FANG stocks
no longer called FANG.
Obviously, Facebook is now
META, Google is now Alphabet.
But these big tech companies,
that's Alphabet, Apple,
Netflix, Nvidia, some
of those bigger names
that you've seen, this
chart is actually made up of
Apple, SNOW, AMD, Tesla, Amazon,
Netflix, Microsoft, Google.
But you see that major
significant outperformance there
of those stocks,
those big tech names up
about 50% over the past year.
When you bring it into
just so far year-to-date
starting from January,
those stocks have risen more
than 70% while the equal weighted S&P 500,
the S&P is weighted by
the biggest companies
have the biggest weights.
But if you take that and you say, okay,
all 500 companies in the
S&P have the same weighting.
Well that index has not risen
but about 1% so far this year.
And that is a significant
difference from what we've seen
from big tech, which is
what leads the index.
And that's rising by
about 70% year to date.
So this chart is illustrating
the significant difference
in overall performance of the market.
Those big tech names having a huge year.
The rest of the market not really,
kind of being left behind.
Last thing we wanna talk
about is US Retail sales.
I wanna put one more chart up here.
Actually we've got two more charts.
But first, let's put this
chart up here on your screen.
This is the month over month
change in Retail sales.
Now if you look on that chart
you can see four of the last
six months have been negative
and you're seeing a very
choppy movement, right?
You're seeing some months
Retail sales are down
some months they're up.
Now I want to compare that to
let's show you the year over
year change in Retail sales.
Well there you get a
much more clear picture
of what's been happening.
Retail sales have been slowing down
consistently year over year.
When you look at it, we're
seeing a slowdown now
to about 2.5% percent of the last reading.
And this does not factor in inflation.
So this is just how
much people are spending
compared to the year before.
So even though prices are going up
and overall sales are increasing, right,
you're seeing more sales
because prices are higher,
it's just about how much
money was brought in.
Well, you're seeing a
decline in Retail sales.
So even though we've still
got inflation up 5% last month
you saw Retail sales only
up about 2.5% percent.
And that shows you that
you're seeing a defined
and clear slowdown of the consumer.
How much does that continue
or how much does that trend change?
We will find out on
Thursday and that chart
just illustrating what we had seen
from Retail sales coming in.
So will consumers continue to spend?
How will the Fed react to the CPI data
and what will the CPI
inflation data tell you?
We will find all that out this week.
It is a big week, the rubber
meeting the road in a big way.
So listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on Market Takes.
Thank you so much for looking
forward to the week with me.
I'm Dion Rabouin, Reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
We will be with you
tomorrow morning at 10:00 AM
breaking down the CPI report.
I hope you'll be with us when
we do it again next time.